Watch as I knit my RTR hat.
Now, I know it's a funny name, but you'll
quickly see why it's named RTR.
Use this watch cap as
inspiration for your next hat.
It has a reverse stockinette Hung hem,
a couple of reverse stockinette amd 1x1
rib inserts it's a 4 gore cap and it's
gathered at the top,
allowing for a ponytail.
When you build your pattern,
be sure to account for negative ease.
My mannequin's head is 22 inches,
so I built my pattern to a finished size
of 20 inches. Before I started knitting,
I also sketched out my texture
stripes. The body of my hat,
the H dimension in my pattern was 43 rows,
so I decided that each of my stripes would
be six rows alternating stockinette,
reverse stockinette and hand
manipulated 1x1 ribbing.
Start by casting on with waste
yarn and ravel cord.
I knit for about an inch and a half.
Then I turned the tension to the loosest
setting (the largest number) and I also
released the yarn from the tension wire
and held the working yarn
by hand and knit one row.
This created a really loose turning row.
For the second half I knit the same
number of rows for the hem.
For more tips about hems,
especially one of my favorites of picot
hem, please visit the Knit It Now
classroom "Hem and Edges".
To create a hem with the purl side
showing, remove, turn and rehang the hem.
Now, I don't have a garter bar for this
machine, so I used a circular hand
knitting needle to remove the stitches.
I turned the work so that the knit side
was facing me and then rehung each
of the stitches back in the needles.
Once the stitches were hung back
on the machine, I picked up the open
cast on stitches to hang the hem.
I then immediately knit my first stripe,
which is stockinette
in contrast to the reverse stockinette hem.
I continued to follow my plan,
and I alternated RTR and hand-reformed one
by one sections to finish
this "H" part of my hat.
At this gauge, re-forming these stitches
wasn't too tedious,
and I really like the texture.
So planning the public side of my
knitting, I started to shape the wedges.
After dividing the number of stitches
according to my pattern,
I scrapped off each section.
To scrap off with my working yarn
at the right, I pulled all the needles
to hold and set my carriage
to holding the working yarn.
I was then able to free pass over
to the left side of my knitting.
I put the first group of needles into work
and then just scrapped off those needles.
I put the second group of needles in work
and scrapped them off and repeated
for the third group of needles.
Then free pass to the right to get
the carriage back to the side
with the working yarn so I can
continue knitting that first wedge.
Now I'm ready to start shaping
the wedge according to my pattern.
I'm decreasing one stitch
on each side every row.
Notice that I'm decreasing two stitches
in from the edge, and I'm
working a two-step decrease.
For more shaping tips, visit Knit it Now shaping tutorials.
I want to leave an opening for a ponytail.
So instead of decreasing down to one or
two stitches, as the pattern tells me,
I only decreased down to eight stitches
on each wedge a little over one inch.
I then created eyelets in each wedge
to create holes so I could cinch
up the top of the hat with I-cord.
If you haven't yet knit I-cord,
check the Knit It Now Classroom I-cord
on the machine.
It's easy.
After transferring stitches
for the eyelets,
I continued to knit for about an inch,
and then I bound off each of the wedges
using the I-cord.
The hat can be gathered closed,
or the opening can accommodate
a ponytail or a messy bun.